hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to another hazel
devlog so
this week i thought i would talk a
little bit about what i'm going to be
doing with hazel over the next
month or so and what our kind of larger
scale goals were this was coming up a
lot on the discord over the last
week and uh i don't think i did i do a
devlog last week was that the bloom one
i'm not sure but anyway i'll leave the
last the last devlog
linked up there in case you want to
check it out basically was just me
talking about how i've added bloom and
emission and all that stuff to hazel and
i guess following on from that kind of
stuff
i really needed to do a lot of work with
hazel's material system
because up until now what we've
basically been doing
is just kind of editing materials that
were imported directly from the mesh and
we weren't able to actually
create materials as assets and then be
able to like save them as separate files
and
you know drag on existing materials from
like the content browser onto
entities and onto meshes and stuff like
that so that is all kind of done
and that's kind of what today's video is
going to be about
but in general before we get into that
kind of stuff i want to talk a little
bit about
like what is going to happen over the
next month or two with hazel and my kind
of direction for it
overall longer term as well so first of
all as you guys know
um i've been building hazel for a while
it's been a little bit over two years we
have somewhat of like a hazel core team
filled with contributors
um who have contributed various paths to
the engine the engine is growing
at a pretty nice rate and all of us are
having fun with it
but the question that keeps popping up a
lot from a lot of different people
is but like what is your goal with hazel
why are you making a game engine
you know are you trying to compete with
unreal or unity like what is going on
here and
i have like addressed this question
before i'll leave a video
up there i actually don't know if that
video is still relevant and if my
opinions have changed
because it is like at least a year old
but
the idea is that like no like you know
we're not trying to necessarily compete
with unity or unreal
um my end goal with hazel is to be able
to create content with it and i think
i've said
that before like i want to be able to
literally use it as a platform for me to
like create
games and other kind of uh experiences
we'll say um you know just like like a
game developer might pick up unity and
use that to make something and then the
game is kind of the result of that the
game is like that kind of artwork that
they've made
you know for me it's just that but i'm
building my own platform to make
art on and that's kind of what's
happening with hazel
so like i'm not planning to ever really
sell hazel i'm not planning to like
you know commercialize the actual game
engine
it's like i'm i am planning to hopefully
release some games with it
but that's kind of not really the point
and then the other side of it is
obviously
like i want to use it as an educational
platform
to teach game engines and graphics and
all of that kind of stuff
and a good example of that is we looked
at bloom last time and a lot of you
wanted me to show the kind of
in-depth process of how bloom works and
so i'm going to make a video on that and
obviously hazel is going to be the
platform upon which i can show that so
that's kind of what i'm talking about
that and then also the game engine
series now up until like now i want to
say
we have been jamming in so many features
into hazel like
you know i wake up in the morning i'm
filled with ideas i'm filled with
anxiety of like oh man we have to have
this and we have to have that and we
have to jam this in and that in and
you know why don't we have this yet or
i'll see something cool in a youtube
video that someone's made in unreal or
unity and i'll be like man i wish hazel
had that
and then i'll like i'll it's very easy
to get kind of overwhelmed
but i think that we are literally at the
point now
where hazel is more than capable of
making
a large a large variety of games i mean
we can you know render 3d graphics write
c sharp scripts for interaction you know
we have physics we have audio
we have like a runtime we have all of
these things
that you can use to make a game that
it's easy to kind of get caught up with
you know playing triple a games that are
coming out and then being like oh
but we don't have global elimination
so i can't make a game which of course
is ridiculous because of course you can
make a game without that you don't need
all of these new features
and in fact um i think that it's really
useful to set limitations on yourself to
force you to be creative in other ways i
really enjoyed
the time when i made a game in one hour
using hazel i have that video linked up
there in case you want to check it out
where hazel that was like using the
public kind of game engine series
version of hazel where hazel was so
stripped
down at that point it was basically like
a little framework and so i remember in
that video like i didn't have bloom
um and and i needed the triangles to
glow and so i had to just go into
photoshop and you know create a texture
that had like um you know some kind of
glow effect on it and then i could tint
that using a shader
like you know the result is almost the
same as if i had
had bloom like it's not that different
but i was forced to kind of be creative
and think outside the box for that
specific example because
hazel just didn't have those features
and i think that i'm getting a little
bit too concerned with like whether or
not we have this or whether or not we
have that
and then i need to just take a step back
and realize well actually we have
all we really need to make a game at the
moment so
why don't we focus on refining that
experience
and actually creating some content with
hazel and then maybe we can get back to
the more kind of cooler
features later in fact i've actually
even hired someone who's working with me
in the office right now
to basically work on making games and
other content with hazel because i
truly believe that hazel is at the point
where we can start making content with
it we can start making games with it but
i'm just so busy making like youtube
videos and working on hazel's core
technology that
i don't even have that much time to use
it so having someone to kind of do that
is i think really cool and so over the
next like month or two probably
i'm going to be focusing on not really
adding new
like feature features to hazel but
refining hazel's existing
experience so making making it a joy
to develop games in hazel instead of
like
you know having all of these list of
little minor things that wouldn't take
more than a day to add but having them
kind of be missing
and thus not really being able to either
make
a game at all or like you know struggle
in certain areas of making the game or
just you know
pulling your hair out the whole time
because you can't undo
anything and to be honest like as much
as the kind of graphics rendering side
of me
really wants to add more like stuff to
the renderer or play around with that
there's also something extremely
satisfying about just going back
over the work you've done and just
refining it because i guess
you already know that everything works
it's just about optimizing it it's just
about optimizing the experience you know
adding little icons everywhere
just you know it's it's in a way it's
easy and for i think for me
you know it's it has been stressful at
times working on hazel because
a lot of the things that i attempt to do
like i don't know if they're gonna work
or not and if they don't work i feel
like
i've wasted so much time where i could
have actually made some
extra videos or you know implemented a
you know fix
something in hazel or made it a better
experience but instead i've spent all my
time
trying to you know do this and it wasn't
even worth it
which i don't know i think i need to
relax a little bit but
that's honestly how i feel at times it's
actually kind of fun watching uh
the games being made in the background
anyway all of that aside let's dive in
and take a look at some of the new
material uh
features i guess that have uh now been
introduced into hazel
so i just have a little basic scene here
this is nothing really that special
um and i'm gonna show you like the
material workflow
and again this isn't like groundbreaking
but it didn't exist in hazel before and
it is now here
which i think is pretty exciting so
let's take a look so um
the idea is that at the moment if we
just select this existing entity
uh what i've done is i've set up a
directionalized skylight and we have
this like test scene which is this now
the test scene is actually made up of
five different sub meshes there's a wall
there's a ground
there's these three objects here and uh
you can see over here
in the properties panel the mesh
component actually has this new
materials
kind of uh area that didn't used to
exist before and this is kind of similar
to what you might expect to see like in
unity
we have basically like a wall sphere
cone cube ground these are the names of
the materials within blender
and obviously they've kind of been
imported because you can see this here
if i was to open this
fbx file which is really being rendered
here in blender then we would be able to
see
you know these materials having been
created in in blender
and so we're seeing them here but the
thing is we can't really edit them uh
i mean we can technically if i open up
this materials panel here
you can see the materials and if i click
on like sphere you know i can actually
change the sphere color
um but that's editing like the direct
kind of materials which you should
really probably shouldn't do because you
know you might as well just
kind of make the material the way you
want it in blender if you want then
import it but then if you want to have
dynamic materials or
you want to reset the materials within
hazel itself
then you should just create a material
and drag it into this material slot and
that's kind of the workflow that we
expect
so if i come over here into this
materials place over here you'll see
that we have
a few materials here so like um you know
green emission
if i double click um it opens up the
material editor i'm going to move it
i guess i'll pop it over here because
the face cam is in the way over there
but basically this material editor
um is the kind of editor for this
particular asset at the moment it
doesn't actually display which asset is
being edited
but if i select hazel text you can see
it switches to something else so if we
go back to like green and mesh and
you'll see it's just a green material
with like an emission value for a
roughness value of 0.4
if i drag this in to like i don't know
let's just make the
cube emit so if i drag it into material
3 which is that cube material you can
see now we have that emissive
material there and uh i can actually go
over here and obviously play with like
the emission
um play with like the color all of that
stuff is
fine because it's all like you know it's
all there
um this kind of material is linked now
to this material now you'll notice
there's also a little bit of an x here
if i press that it's going to revert to
using the meshes material so whatever
material was imported with the mesh
we're now going to be using that so
let's kind of drag that back in
and you can see we have this uh emissive
material
so that's all fine um and also this
material itself will be all serialized
and saved
at the moment the icon is just that i
made this like in photoshop in five
minutes but i want to uh basically have
like a
rent you know a rendered sphere with
that material that we can just display
as an icon like a thumbnail here
um kind of like the engines usually do
it i can also open this externally
and if i do hold on let me kind of drag
this over here
and then you can see what this material
actually is so it's called green
emission.h material
for hazel material and this is what it's
actually storing so we have like an
albedo color which you saw there
um you know when i edit this kind of
stuff it will automatically serialize
when the editing has been finished
um and then uh you know we also have
these maps here so albedo map normal map
metals map and roughness map because we
can of course
drag in some sort of texture so
let's see where would this be we have
like um i think
inside textures bricks there's like this
kind of brick material so maybe let's
let's um you know well let's make a new
material and i'll show you how that
works
so if we go into materials right click
new material and then i can call it
something like
uh let's just make this like the the
floor maybe i mean i guess we've got a
ground material but
i'll call it floor i'll double click on
it to open it here let's make it white
so it doesn't tint our texture
and then i will go into textures bricks
and we have these um
bricks that i think i got from
texturehaven.com
so we have like the diffuse i can just
drag that in and then you can see now
we've got that diffused if i hover over
this it'll tell me where it is
and let's just apply it to the ground so
i'll just drag it into ground and of
course
i just try to drag the texture into
ground for some reason let's not do that
let's go back to materials
and then we have our floor material
which i would we'll drag into ground
so now you can see that we have that
actual uh um
texture there and if i open this
externally you can see that we now have
the asset handle
for that particular albedo map
serialized to this floor so we can
of course you know save this and
relaunch it and as expected everything
is that you know it's funny hearing me
say this because of course
it would save why wouldn't it save but
obviously
the work for it to save needs to have
been done so me as a software engineer
as a developer
going into this knowing that like okay
we've done this and this and this and
this i kind of want to explain that
during a devlog
but then someone watching this who's
just like a user might be like
you had to add saving like that's not
just done automatically like why
wouldn't it be
um but anyway and then if we go back to
you know that bricks obviously we can
drag in like
normal maps and then we have these kind
of weird normal maps this really is not
supposed to be this big this texture
um and then you know we have like a
roughness map as well um and then
that's kind of uh now our i guess brick
texture
so there you go and then obviously you
know i can take that asset and i can
apply it to anything else i can
you know control it and tint it and do
whatever i want with it and it all looks
kind of nice
so that's kind of the idea and then
obviously you can clear
these i don't know if i'll keep them in
the same kind of way as they are but
with those little x's there but you know
we can edit these materials
however you like and there's also like a
c-sharp api to be able to access them
from the scripts and manipulate them
live uh
as you might want to do if you want like
certain colors to change during like the
runtime as a quick little
uh other thing that i'll show i have we
have this like asset manager panel which
again i will drag you know let's just
keep it here maybe or i'll drag it here
this asset manager panel basically shows
everything that the asset manager sees
so the asset manager has a whole lot of
stuff here
and so if i take a look at um you know
one of these materials they will
exist within this asset manager so
here's a quick little example
um you know i mean we had the floor we
looked at the floor
actually got rid of the texture that was
in the floor but if we drag in like a
texture
into the floor i'll go back and i'll
drag in that diffuse
um and then we take a look at the actual
file itself
so the file uses this albedo map if i
paste that albedo map here
you can see what it actually maps to so
it's it's easy to kind of be able to
look at
you know how the asset registry actually
sees all of this stuff and then you can
like diagnose issues with missing
with missing references or whatever
other stuff um
including uh you know how like materials
you know they
they themselves are actual um
assets as well so you can see i can see
a bunch of like well this is just me
searching for the word material so it's
going to come up with materials but then
also other stuff that
might not be a material necessarily but
has the word material
in it um but then if i take a look at
like i don't know we made like a green
emission material you can see that it
is just a hazel asset like everything
else it's got a handle
and so anything that refers to that
particular handle can refer to this and
it's cool to have this kind of
indirection because it also means that
we can you know we can do a lot of
things with that handle that handle
doesn't have to be
loaded all the time that handle could be
rewired to point to some other material
we can asynchronously load things and
then just
you know use that handle when it's valid
and when it's not just
ignore it you know use a default kind of
missing material or just
nothing at all um you know there's so
many things we can kind of do with this
like hot reloading there's
you know having that kind of system and
it's been in place for a while
inside hazel it's just not something
that i've really talked about um but i
just
i guess i feel like talking about it now
so um so yeah just a little bit of a
look at
how kind of materials work uh inside
hazel anyway i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button
don't forget you can also help support
the development of hazel and all of my
youtube videos and everything that i do
here on youtube by going to patreon.com
slash the churno you'll also get access
to everything you're seeing here in fact
i pushed all of these material
uh changes like earlier today so they're
all kind of live so i hope they work
properly but
we'll find out soon enough huge thank
you as always to everyone who does help
support the development of hazel of
course we wouldn't be here
doing all this stuff if it wasn't for
you guys so huge thank you
let me know what you guys want to see in
the next dev vlog i am working on that
bloom video i am actually going to make
it i promise
um i need to find the time to do that
amongst all of the other busy things
that i'm doing
but other than that uh yeah over the
next like few
months maybe not that long maybe like a
month or so
i am going to hardcore focus on
improving the hazel experience improving
everything we've got
optimizing you know making all of this
stuff as smooth as possible
thank you all for watching i will see
you next time goodbye
[Music]
you